there were times that we didn't use  condoms because it was only to prevent  against pregnancy did Charlie ever come  inside of you yes he did yes  during my menstrual right time just as  as any of my other ex-boyfriends I would  let them during that time so knowing I  mean this is such high-risk behavior  you really had a really sort of lucky  break that you're not hiv-positive for a  year Howard for a year for a year a  solid year when he knew he knew had he  told you do you think you would have  said I'm leaving or do you think you  might have stayed with a guy who was HIV  positive I would know no I would not I I  would not have stayed because there's I  loved him I loved myself more